good afternoon everybody i'm matt welch
from reason tv
here at the denver state capitol uh
denver is the
site this week of the democratic
national convention i'm here at the
capitol
with a state senator from colorado a
democrat turned republican turned
democrat
and you'll correct me where i'm wrong
senator bob hagedorn
he's been in the legislature here for 24
years
tell us a little bit about your journey
from reagan democrat to republican to
democratica
well actually it was democrat to reagan
democrat slash republican back to the
democratic party
and part of it is that i've always been
very independent and i've
had problems uh back in the 70s
realizing that the democrats seem to be
a little more liberal than i was
and so i figured that you know i kind of
liked some of the stuff that reagan was
saying
but more so i didn't like where the
direction of jimmy carter's presidency
was taking this country
and uh the liberals in the democratic
party so i figured
well i wasn't doing anything miles
become a republican
and uh unfortunately i got engaged in a
at a time when there seemed to be an
assault on
individual rights and freedoms just
beginning in the republican party
starting with a woman's right to choice
and
so very quickly i realized that
i probably didn't exactly fit in the
republican party either
and uh but anyway i wasn't that engaged
at the time in the
80s in politics and kind of dropped out
and uh then late 87 finally decided that
well
the republicans were just moving in to
too far of a direction from where i was
and
at least i knew whether the democrats
were and i felt that i could probably
stomach the liberals better than i could
the
arch conservatives talk a little bit
about your feeling about sort of bush
administration
and even the putative mccain
administration record or approach
towards individual liberty issues that
you seem to care about
well one of the things that basically
since i first campaigned for the
legislature and i was first elected to
the
state house is that i felt my role as
much as anything else were protecting my
constituents
rights liberties and freedoms that has
always been my number one priority
and regardless of whether they're
democrat initiated or republican
initiated
is that i'm not a guy that's keen on
seeing any of our
rights liberties and freedoms taken away
from us and certainly we
uh i mean i like everybody else was just
devastated by 9 11. however uh we
compounded that tragedy with the patriot
act
and we've seen a slow i think decline in
our individual rights liberties and
freedoms
unfortunately a lot of americans seem to
be willing to
give up some of those for the idea of
security
but then where do you draw the line with
government if you do not reign in
government
government will continue to creep along
and
pretty soon you can wake up one morning
and hey you have no rights liberties or
freedoms
and that's what my main concern is uh
certainly with uh
uh you know there's there's a senator
mccain who's running for the presidency
in 2008
who seems to be a little different from
the senator mccain from 2000
kind of like the guy from 2000 but right
now it looks like it's going to be
another four years of
of another eight years of the bush
administration particularly
slow deterioration of our individual
freedoms which
you know it still seems incredibly
ironic considering it's the republicans
who historically you could kind of trust
at times
to protect your rights liberties and
freedoms but you know only in certain
arenas just like the democrats
only in limited arenas is there a sort
of
libertarian flavored backlash in the
mountain west particularly against the
republican party
you hear some sort of belly hood
movement in that direction but does it
actually tangibly exist do you think
well i would say very much so if you
looked at the west i think you will find
that the west is
easily more libertarian than the midwest
or the east
and one of the things is that i thought
you know
for a long time kind of the hallmark of
particularly the republican party in
colorado was
a real protection of individual freedoms
and i think that what we've seen now is
that
the democrats we have majorities in the
house and senate
as well as of course the governor but we
have elected
we have democrats in seats that have
very well performing republican numbers
but the problem is
is that the republicans have nominated
candidates who literally want to take
away people's rights
i mean very significantly abortion
rights is uh
area that resonates very well and
we have places like jefferson county
that
you know we hold the majority of state
elected offices
house and senate legislative offices in
jefferson county
jefferson county should be predominantly
republican in terms of their
representation down here but they have
chosen to go
with shall we say evangelical republican
candidates
which infringes upon i think an overall
uh level of uh
respect for freedoms and into you know
in our rights and so i think that uh the
republicans by having moving away from
barry goldwater
into this more evangelical direction
has definitely cost them support in the
western states
because you know we appreciate
individual rights liberties and freedoms
and republicans have been sensitive to
that and enjoyed those rights
and now their own candidates are saying
well you know we're going to take these
away from you
that's great uh from the denver state
house i'm with
senator bob hagedorn this has been matt
welch reason tv thank you very much